yo what up it's jamie foxx you are not
prepared for day shift this is going to
be like something you've never seen
before
this movie has what i call eating
popcorn moments you know when you're
like oh
in this movie i'm in the business of
chasing down vampires and getting money
for fangs good energy guys here it comes
good friend of mine jj perry we started
his stuntmen together way back in the
late 90s having done all the john wick
films and then reading the script i
think jj makes day shift a fresh take
i love the idea of the vampires because
it takes yourself a notch
jj's taken some vampire mythology and
put it in crazy situations of gunfights
and car and motorcycle chases
we're making something that you've never
seen before it's fun
and the stunts that you see is amazing
and it's
practical the way jj uses all of his
stunt women and men is brilliant so i
cannot wait for people to get a dose of
this and find out how to kill
vampires right here on day shift
[Music]
[Music]
you